all right this weekend more more
disturbing accusations emerged about
Hollywood executive and major major
Democratic donor Harvey Weinstein now
after mounting allegations of sexual
harassment Weinstein was actually fired
by his own company that's good news
now while details of what Weinstein is
accused of doing or beyond shocking what
is even more disturbing is the fact that
for 30 years this guy has been praised
by the left by liberals by Hollywood and
Democrats now let me explain the website
vaak given they didn't analyze almost
1,400 Academy Awards acceptance speeches
Harvey Weinstein ranked second for the
most thanked person now back in 2012
Meryl Streep even jokingly called
Weinstein God and she is one of only
just a handful of celebrities that are
now speaking out against Weinstein in
the face of these accusations but
where's the widespread outrage
condemnation from Hollywood
I thought they cared about women's
rights now if the tables will turn and
this was a conservative in the same
situation Hollywood liberals would be
enraged the media would be enraged
however since it's one of their own it's
mostly crickets the silence is deafening
another example of how Hollywood has
ignored this scandal according to Axios
look at this all these late-night
comedians Jimmy Kimmel Jimmy Fallon Seth
Meyers James Corden guess what they
didn't mention it at all during their
shows and Saturday Night Live the show
that ruthlessly mocks president Trump
and all conservatives well they had
jokes written about Weinstein yet they
never made air and what's worse is that
the SNL creator Lorne Michaels he tells
the Daily Mail that the reason he didn't
go after Weinstein is because it's quote
a New York thing really well Michaels
really meant it's a hypocrisy thing and
you can't forget about attorney Lisa
bloom pretty much any time a woman
accused as a conservative of something
she swoops in to represent them with a
major press conference to attack
conservatives big surprise Blum was
actually advising Weinstein before
resigning this weekend and blued made
the announcement via tweeter
Twitter Don tweeter quote I have
resigned as an attorney
an advisor for Harvey Weinstein my
understanding is that mr. Weinstein and
his board are moving forward and toward
an agreement what does that even mean
now you would think since bloom is the
so called champion of women's rights
that she would never ever consider
working for Weinstein her hypocrisy is
stunning but it's not surprising now the
same goes for many Democrats they took
piles of money from Harvey Weinstein and
only now after these allegations
surfaced some just a few not all of them
are beginning to give it back or give it
a charity look at these statistics
Weinstein donated an estimated forty
four thousand dollars to Hillary Clinton
since 1999 and that's on top of the 15
grand he shelled out to a super PAC tied
to Clinton Weinstein also contributed
over fifty six thousand dollars to the
Obama victory fund the Hollywood Big
Shot he gave over ninety seven thousand
dollars to the Democratic National
Committee and he also wrote checks for
over seventy six thousand dollars for
the Democratic Senatorial Campaign
Committee all told the Center for
Responsive Politics calculates Weinstein
contributed over two million dollars to
Democrats
that's only since the year 2000 now some
Democrats they're given some of the
money back or they're donating it to
other liberal causes they think that
cleans their hands but again no
across-the-board outraged no disgust and
we can't forget that the two biggest
beneficiaries of Weinstein's
contributions Barack Obama Hillary
Clinton they have yet to comment
publicly about him if it was a
conservative you think they might have
commented this is what I was telling you
about during the election liberals
claimed to care the most about women's
rights if they did Hillary Clinton and
her Family Foundation would never have
taken money from countries like Saudi
Arabia Qatar Oh mom Kuwait the UAE now
these countries treat women horribly
they kill gays and lesbians many of them
they persecute Christians and Jews you
can't build a temple or a church in
Saudi Arabia so the left is a selective
moral outrage they're completely full of
it on every single issue that they
lecture you that they're more release
period about over Republicans for
example Daily Caller reporting that
there's a coffee shop owner in Seattle
Washington we have the videotape of a
group of Christian anti-abortion
activists get kicked out after a mile
tirade all because the owner couldn't
tolerate their presence welcome here
can't hear it is talking about anal sex
with Jesus Christ just to offend people
have you heard anything about this story
in the mainstream left-wing destroy
Trump media probably not you probably
didn't even see the tape until right now
and guess what you probably never will
and here's why the left they say they
care about religious liberty especially
when it comes to Christians in this
country well guess what why do I believe
if this was another religion do I
suspect there would be widespread
outrage lawsuits the left would be
apoplectic the media would be covering
it 24/7 365 but in this case they're
Christians doesn't seem to matter to
them and then there's this example that
the Washington free beacon is reporting
on you have a group of students trying
to shut down an exam at Berkeley because
of the stress that they are enduring and
claiming racism watch this
we now have reach it reached a point of
cultural insanity the left claims
they're all for free speech but look
what happens at the so-called home of
freedom of speech and we also cannot
forget the Conservatives have pretty
much been essentially blocked from
speaking at UC Berkeley the left doesn't
care about this country's history
doesn't care about its culture just look
at these videos from earlier today
all the Columbus Day protests liberals
they have no problem supporting people
defacing vandalizing our history and
statues you know what what about what
other people think what about tolerance
it's just like what we saw when leftist
were tearing down and removing
Confederate monuments here it goes even
further now the one thing the left does
not seem to care about is the NFL when
they disrespect our flag our country and
the thousands and thousands of Americans
that fought bled and died fighting under
that flag and protesting they're out
there protesting the national anthem
this weekend the vice president Mike
Pence he walked out of yesterday's NFL
game following national anthem protests
the vice president and the second lady
Karen pence attended the game in
Indianapolis and after a handful of
49ers well refused to honor the flag
pence and his wife rightly headed for
the exits the vice president later
tweeted quote
I left today's Colts game because at
POTUS and I will not dignify any event
that disrespects our soldiers our flag
or our national anthem they have a big
debate later in the program and
president Trump took to Twitter writing
quote I asked Vice President Penn
to leave the stadium if players kneeled
disrespecting our country I am proud of
him and second lady Karen good for the
vice president taking a stand Americans
are sick and tired of seeing these
players protesting the flag and not
honoring those brave men and women that
fought bled and died and by the way this
is a country that gives them an
opportunity to make millions of dollars
playing a game NFL owners they're
beginning to start to realize that
millions are at stake here and the
American people are fed up for what is
now blatantly disrespectful behavior
Dallas Cowboys owner Jerry Jones he said
yesterday that players who protest the
national anthem they're not going to
play and the Miami Dolphins owner Steven
Ross he's saying it is incumbent on
players to stand and salute the flag of
the United States finally it's about
time these owners did something because
as Marc Thiessen pointed out a couple of
weeks ago the NFL's game operation
manual says all players must be on the
sidelines for the national anthem they
must stand at attention face the flag
hold their helmets in their left hand
and refrain from talking or face
discipline such as fine suspensions
and/or forfeiture of draft choices first
offense but by the way you can't do this
in the end zone
well you can't twerk or you can't be
offensive to the other team or you can't
gloat in the end zone
a lot of rules restricting freedom of
speech you can't put 911 we'll never
forget on your cleats and you can't on a
police officer slain in Dallas of course
after the vice president left the NFL
game the left the liberal mainstream
media went into full-on freakout mode
ESPN's Jamil Hill remember her
she's the liberal host who tweeted the
president Trump was a white supremacist
well earlier tonight Hill was suspended
by ESPN for two weeks after calling for
fans to boycott advertisers of the
Dallas Cowboys now it's interesting how
she got suspended for that not for
attacking the President of the United
States
here's the bottom line tonight this
country is divided culturally culturally
because the left is hypocritical and
inconsistent
they only feign phony moral outrage but
only when it suits their political
agenda
they only care about their only outraged
over the conservative scandals not
liberal ones and they pretend to have
the moral authority on issues like race
women's rights gay rights and the list
goes on and on the truth is this the
left has been lying about all of that
for a long time and this Harvey
Weinstein scandal proves all of it for
the right price the left and their
silence can be bought